conference today's speaker probably
needs no introduction since most of you
know him in fact you know usually I have
a piece of paper when I introduce the
speaker but I know him well enough and I
don't need that anyway some Steve
Bedrich who is a somewhat recent
graduate of our program and now is doing
very well as a faculty member here
mostly in the center for spoken language
understanding but also in our department
in de maiz is going to come and give us
an update on all of his research so
Steve is a native of the area grew up
here went off to Colorado College and
then came and did his PhD in our program
funded under the NLM training grant and
I think he had a really good advisor and
then was brought on by CSL you where
he's continued work in NLP text mining
and a variety of topics and continues to
work with the Department and so forth
and so he's going to give us an update
on his research is this thing going
people hear me yes all right excellent
well thank you all for coming and thanks
for the introduction bill as bill said
I'm on the faculty of the senator spoken
language understanding and we'll be
talking today about some of my recent
research i'll be talking about kind of
two area two big sort of project areas
one on medical information retrieval and
another on assistive technologies for
primary progressive aphasia so first I
wanted to really quickly do a slide
about CSL users because I know that not
everybody at ohsu knows that we exist or
what we do so we are a center under the
Institute on disability development
which is sort of what the CDR see turned
into some years back
and our sort of major area of focus is
on algorithms for speech and language
technology but also signal general
signal processing for of biomedical
signals and then applying those
technologies to typically diagnosis or
assessment technologies but also repeat
remediation as well and we have a really
actually quite diverse faculty in terms
of research areas we have speech people
we have an image processing people we
have machine learning folks we have NLP
people like me and we have a we work in
a wide variety of sort of medical
medical domains you know there's my own
work in AC and I are but we also have a
big project on automating assessment of
autism we have projects on studying
language and speech use of people of
people who are aging to try to detect
mild cognitive impairment really a quite
a wide variety of projects if anybody's
interested you know I'm we're always
happy to talk so we also have a ms and
ph.d program in computer science and
electrical engineering that we're hoping
to find more ways to plug in with D mice
and vice versa on that and several of us
actually have joint appointments in D
mice so part of me coming today is
hopefully trying to you know build more
connections between our groups so that
was just the quick preliminary there and
so the two projects i'll be talking
about from my work are again information
retrieval and then faiza naac so
information retrieval plays a really
important role in in biomedicine i'm
focusing today on sort of medical
aspects and there's a number of
different ways that I are plays a role
some of them may be more or less
expected so from a patient's perspective
there's all kinds of information needs
that arise when you're sort of going
through your life as a patient you know
what's this funny-looking rash on my arm
how I should make here we get before we
go to the doctor my doctor says the rash
is idiopathic what does that even mean
does my new skin medication of side
effects and so on and so forth lots of
things that patients might be searching
for information on providers also have
information needs and use IR systems to
address them what is this funny-looking
rash on my patient soccer
it is actually quite surprising how
often doctors use Google these days
right so is this new drug for treating
dermatitis better than the old drug what
proportion of patients on that on the
new drug experienced a certain side
effect or group of side effects are
there any other patients in my practice
or in my patient panel who tried that
drug in what happened to them when they
did so these are all can be fit into a
few different categories of information
need right cuick question answering
style searching you know what is this
rash searching over EHR records so we
have a collection of patients we want to
find things that happened in their
visits using text search clinical
decision support so having a system
somehow in you know infer what
information will be relevant to it to a
provider at a given point during the
care process and then presenting it to
them in some way searching through
biomedical literature for research
purposes or for treatment purposes and
then sort of another buzzword the cohort
development or cohort discovery right we
have a big database of patients and we
have some description of patients that
we want to identify a subset of you know
patients who are on this drug who are
between this age in that age who have a
diagnosis of X Y or Z you know usually
for trial development but also for
general epidemiological research and
quality improvement all those kinds of
classic informatics things that one
might want might want to do I are plays
of course a key role in all of this from
a sort of computer science ii standpoint
the medical domain poses a number of
very interesting i our challenges so
compared to general web search medical
language has a lot of extreme synonymy
load there's lots of different ways to
say the same thing and lots of jargon
and to a degree that you don't often see
and many other I our domains how many
how many different ways are there to
describe a heart attack you know well um
LSN is probably half dozen different
words that that depend you know that all
to a greater or lesser extent might
refer to a heart attack then if you ever
read say clinical notes thinking more
focusing a bit more on searching over
clinical records there
often very quirky and obscure ways that
doctors word their notes and and and and
then they do this not to make searching
hard but because they're communicating
generally foreign audience of other
professionals and there's a rich and
long-standing linguistic tradition
within medicine of how you write a note
right and and and the way they write on
Paul Garmin can go on for hours about
how the way that you write a note or the
words you choose to use or not use can
what will themselves communicate
something independent of the actual
words you chose right if you word it one
way the doctor reading it will hot will
be able to interpret it at a deeper
level than then somebody who didn't know
about that sort of linguistic background
and you know again general web search
doesn't tend to have that as much
getting more specific there'll be lots
of complicated edema sorry complicated
negation expressions right so if you're
just searching for you know patients
that had edema and you're going on
keyword search you will you know be
triggered by things that say no sign of
edema which of course is the opposite of
what you want negation is always a
problem in NLP but it's a particularly
big problem when searching over medical
notes because of the amazing variety of
ways the doctors have to express
negation and then have you use of
passive voice which makes some kinds of
syntactic analysis more challenging the
again the absence of a concept might
itself be important right a doctor
reading a reading a report of a physical
exam will know what things they you know
looking at the section say on head and
neck they're going to know that the 20
things that are involved in a head neck
exam and the fact that 18 of those
weren't mentioned is going to
communicate something to the doctor
right they're going to is going to
communicate that those 18 things we're
not notable and we're not important and
figuring out how to kind of capture that
is very challenging right so thinking
more generally the information needs as
we saw in the examples before are very
diverse and they can be very complicated
and hard to express they can also be
ambiguous it's it's different from shop
it you know searching for product
reviews where you generally know more or
less exactly what you're trying to find
out it isn't always clear what you're
looking for if you're looking for
patients
had a certain problem you know there's
probably a lot of other contextual
information that you know about your
knee that might not get expressed in the
query that you might not even know how
to express obviously the quantities of
data can be quite large that's often
it's not web scale as such but it can
still be large enough to be difficult
and it can also be large enough to be
difficult to know how to present to a
user and then there's this interesting
mix of structured and unstructured data
so a clinical record will have obviously
a free text progress note but it will
also have you know a dozen or two dozen
structured elements you know lab test
results coded problem list entries any
kind of you know blood pressure readings
anything that you might go and say a
flowchart and epic you know will be
captured hopefully in some kind of
structured form and many information
needs can make use of both structured
and unstructured information traditional
text I are generally ignores the
unstructured information or doesn't have
a straightforward of a framework for
fitting it in so that's part of why
medical IR is so interesting to me from
from an IR standpoint thus far most of
what I've done with medical ir has sort
of been in the context of these shared
tasks so as a field even even even more
than most CS fields ir has this really
strong rich tradition of evaluation
empirical evaluation and and doing
empirical evaluations with shared tasks
where you get many researchers together
you have a common data said you have a
common set of queries we all run our
systems on the queries and then we have
a way to meaningfully compare our
results and starting when I was doing a
PhD with though I got involved in a
number of these shared tasks and ohs use
participated both as a team submitting
queries but also on the administrative
side helping to organize share tasks and
collect relevance judgments and that's
been a big way that I've been involved
two big kind of families of shared tasks
that have application in biomedicine our
trek which is the text retrieval
evaluation conference which has been
going on for actually I think it's just
the text retrieval conference now that I
think about it it's been going on for
well over 20 years and it's run by the
national institutes of standard
standards and
nology and they have tracks that cover a
wide variety of kinds of I are you know
general web search all the way down to
you know hyper specific you know genomic
stuff that it was just you ran for a
number of years the last several years
they've had medical tracks as well and
then another large set of campaigns or
shared tasks or source for shared tasks
is the clay series as the cross suited
the cross language evaluation form and
it actually grew out of Trek but now is
sort of its own thing and is more
European focused and focuses on again
usually multilingual search problems the
last couple of years they've also had
medical tracks so multilingual medical
data and multilingual medical queries
and searching / / both and we've been
involved in a number of these the one
they'll be talking about today grew out
of the truck med track it was focused on
medical record retrieval and the idea
there was in 2012 who was the idea was
it was sort of case identification for
cohort discovery from a free text
description so we might have a
description like patients treated for
lower extremity chronic wounds and we
had a corpus of about 90,000
de-identified encounters that there are
sort of the progress note from from
either progress notes emergency room
note surgical reports and I think
pathology reports for about seventeen
thousand visits so each visit might have
multiple encounters and the idea was to
identify from the seventeen thousand
visits ones that were responsive to that
query we oh right sorry we also had ICD
codes for them so there was that mix of
structured and unstructured data our
system it does it looks like it fell off
the back of a truck ignore that but I
would point out its interactive in a way
that most people doing these tracks
don't bother making interaction system
sort of something away that I would just
use distinguished itself over the years
the idea was you know you could tuck in
your query and get a result we used
leucine which is an open-source search
package so you put in a query it
searches through the notes and we get a
you know this was a query for the word
monkey and and and what comes out as a
note where somebody has a past history
of an injury from falling off of the
monkey bars so not actually relevant to
to you know it sort of sort of actually
a good a good example of why searching
is tricky over notes right so that's
something from the past medical history
not not about the immediate purpose of
the visit which is probably relevant
probably an important thing to know if
you're wanting to decide whether the
articles relevant so anyway we had the
system it took the free text queries and
then used meta map which is a tool from
the National Library of Medicine that
takes free text and identifies yoma less
concepts in that free text it's
basically a named entity recognizer
that's been tuned to work on this kind
of text and work against the umls and
the idea was it would take something
like patients treated for depression
after myocardial infarction and basic
map it to ICD codes but also take the
rise of disorders or mental depression
and myocardial infarction or infarct or
any of the other doesn't throw other
ones this approach was pretty simplistic
right it's it's basically a bag of words
approach and that it does it's not
taking into account anything about the
structure of the sentence right it's
just setting are these terms present and
trying to be a little bit more clever
about what terms to include and also
taking advantage of that structured
information because we did have
discharged notes and it varied the
performance meta map actually does have
negation capability we didn't use it for
this we should have and and actually did
later on but but it's unclear also how
good is negation detection is it can get
simple negation pretty well more complex
negation less so there's other negation
detection things out there though for
sure the idea of how to incorporate
negation detection into something like
this is also a little bit tricky so
again if it's a simple query you can
just sort of boolean not out the term
that if the text is being negated but as
as we'll see when think when the queries
get more complicated that that approach
starts
to fail but but anywho the important
thing is just that the performance was
okay but very widely by topic that's
that's actually pretty common we had the
system built and then in 2014 they went
and changed the task of us in 2014
something the place we were getting the
notes from decided that they no longer
one of those notes to be available for
research and clamp that of the basically
the their their lawyers clamped down and
track had two people at NIST had to
scramble to rejigger the task and so the
task was a little bit different now the
document collection is pubmed central
from the open access subset so they're
published literature articles and the
page and now we have instead of quick
snippets of a patient we actually have a
full discharge like a full force not
discharge their full summary of the
patient write complete sentences
complicated sentences written in met you
know with with medical what I guess what
I would think it was medical syntax
right and so we have to go from that to
come up with potentially appropriate
articles the the sort of motivating
theme was a it was big model as a
decision support problem right so maybe
the EHR can generate this summary or
maybe the summaries in the HR somewhere
and we want to show the provider
articles that might be relevant to their
treatment it's unclear how realistic
that scenario is but that's sort of the
the the one they went way from the one
they're going with again this year so we
try to old approach and got terrible
results and they were terrible for a
number of reasons I mean everybody got
bad results is actually really hard task
and part of the reason so hard as any of
these kinds of automated query
generating you know any of these any of
these things that like take text and try
to cope with that way to something that
query when the query is this long if
you're just looking like picking out
terms you're going to get a million
terms and most of them aren't actually
going to be relevant and borrowing any
other information of how those terms
relate to each other it's not at all
clear how to put it together into some
kind of query Aaron yeah
it is a hard task for a human being and
the relevance judgment was challenging
we had what about a dozen or so MDS yeah
maybe more like 20 MDS oh okay the way
track usually does relevance judgment is
the the you might start by just taking
your entire back I'm a document
collection going through all of them and
saying whether they're relevant or not
for the query that's unfeasible because
we have under thousand documents so what
they do is everybody does their runs
their system and you have say 20
different people's systems results and
then what you do is you pull them
together and you take the articles that
were most frequently retrieved and you
make a sort of meta set of articles that
is it more tractable size say five
hundred or a thousand and then you have
human judges look over those so some
people's articles that their systems
retrieved never got judged and therefore
get counted is not relevant which is a
sort of problem with that style of
evaluation but it's kind of the best
system anybody's come up with come up
with yet so for this one the many of the
topics didn't have very many relevant
documents at all which was a challenging
aspect of it yeah yes
yeah absolutely yeah and that's what he
gets back to what I was saying about how
how realistic was the scenario I know
that it was a sub subject of much
discussion among the track organizers
and and there was also a lot of
variation across the judges which is not
uncommon in these judgment tasks but
absolutely a lot in this one there was a
lot so it's a part of that's actually
honestly part of what makes that medical
error so interesting to me as the
evaluation story is actually really hard
to it's hard to do and it's interesting
this this is this is the query and and
so the idea was to find articles and
many of them from that it does happen
that many of the articles in the PubMed
Central open access corporate open
access subset our case reports and
Soviet was to find case reports that
looked like that erin was given to the
relevant judges were they told you know
case reports were relevant or not
relevant and where they told that the
subject had to be primarily about the
patients you know primary discard
problem or what kind of guidance where
they give oh we didn't have primary
discharge problems but bill can you
speak to that a little bit since you
were yeah the you know this was actually
a pretty I mean we're proud I am is the
lights on I always use them like
everyone
guys Graham so Aaron's question was
about the the guidance given to the
judges you know I think we might be that
this is a very complex question but just
to get to the gist of it we we did give
them guidance it was hard to give them a
lot of detailed guidance but I mean I
think like what Steve just said is that
you know they got all kinds of different
types of articles out of the medical
literature and those of you who know all
about evidence-based medicine that
there's you know different levels of
evidence and we didn't really go into
that which was a limitation of the tasks
where since this task is going to be run
again this coming year we're hopefully
going to address these the one saving
grace in all this I don't know if you
plan to mention this but it turns out
that relevance judgments don't matter
that much because when you have
different judgments done by different
people the systems that do better with
one set of judgments tend to do better
with other sets of judgments so I mean
it's important to get good judgments but
it's it's not a it doesn't kill the
whole thing that you don't have perfect
ones if you have one set of judgments
and other set of judgments the absolute
differences and scores will be different
but the relative rankings of the
different systems will be usually
preserved so anyway that's a whole other
topic and I do I'm going to actually
move on the budget bid I could also as
you can see talk about evaluation of
this stuff for a very long time as
needed so so we decided that we needed
something a little bit more
sophisticated we began by asking why our
previous system underperformed and one
of the things we identified was that we
end up with these just ridiculously over
specified queries that had every term in
there and and no real notion of which
ones were important or even how to
organize them because the topics were so
long and looking at it again you know
that there's a most of what's actually
important about this about this
description yet
there's important medical words in there
but like most of what's in there is
about how is about the is in the
linguistic structure of the sentences
right if you're just looking for what
words are present or not present that's
not going to actually capture most of
what's interesting about this person so
right okay there we go so relying solely
on the words gave lousy results so what
we wanted to do was find a way to
capture more of that information from
the query and at the same time we didn't
want to go full-on into information
extraction mode because looking at the
at that query you could easily think
about how you could write a program to
like you know assuming that the
sentences were all about people with
diabetes and all about what they didn't
want to do and when went all about with
what they were complaining about you
could probably write like with some you
know regular expressions or template
matching or some other kind of
information extraction approach pluck
out exactly what you wanted and get a
good query from that topic but the
topics were all so different and all set
you know there is over this huge range
of medical subjects and formatted in
different ways we needed something that
would be generic enough to handle
anything and not be overly specific to
say diabetes related stuff so what we
decided to do for this year is where and
by we I mean myself and a PhD student
Joe Adams in CSL you are working on
using linguistic dependency features for
retrieval so what's the linguistic
dependency a dependency grammar is it's
a way of formally representing the
structure of a sentence at a linguistic
level it stands in contrast took well
describes how the different words in a
sentence interact with one another and
the function they're playing together in
the sentence this is in contrast to a
constituents constituency grammar and
once familiar with that which is more
like the sentence diagramming we all
remember from middle school about sort
of the parts of speech of the words and
what what Claude what Klaus is you know
subordinate to what other clause this is
more about the how the how they're doing
rather than the what and I have an
example here so here's a sentence the
aged bottle flies flies fast and here's
a constituency parse and we can see that
we have a verb phrase here flies past
and what makes it a constituency is that
each of these pieces can be sort of
moved around independently within the
sentence and have it still makes an
tactic sense obviously swabbing the VP
and the MP isn't valid in English but in
a more complex sentence you can see how
you
can kind of pick pieces around and have
it still internally make sense the
dependency parse for that sentence looks
like this and it tells us thing tells us
things that the bottle is the subject of
flies and that aged isn't added to
modifier on bottle and so on and so
forth so it's giving us a slightly
different lens with which to pick apart
that sentence and think about how the
words relate to each other just another
example from the manual for the
dependency parser we used you know Bell
based in Los Angeles makes it attributes
electronic computer and building
products and so you can learn things
that you know bells what does the
distributing and that Bell is you know
based in there and that the products are
electronic or computers and so on and so
forth yeah oh so the question was
whether the dependence of Defense parce
is our position dependent they are to
the extent that the way you get them is
usually by doing a constituency parts
parse first and then doing transforms on
that and if the sentence is formed is
malformed then you'll get bad results
out supposedly it is supposed to be more
resistant to things being shuffled
around within a sentence though as long
as it's you know playing by the
syntactic rules so I don't have an
example that kind of illustrates that
coming up so our idea was to use these
dependencies to hopefully get a more
semantically rich representation of the
query than just the simple bag of words
or bag of concepts and we are working
with last year's topics and queries or i
guess the queers all of the topics to
try to tune are trying to tune our
system and get it working and hope so we
will use it for this year's CES so once
we have the dependencies we're not doing
anything terribly fancy with the
retrieval side we're basically just
doing standard vector space retrieval
we're pretending that the dependencies
are words and the in the document
essentially and we're doing you know a
little bit of processing on there but
that part thus far we haven't done
anything too crazy with this idea is not
new the first time we found someone
thinking about this was nineteen
eighty-four the cgiar and then
it pops up now and again depends ities
get used heavily for other information
extraction tasks they get used for
negation detection quite often grammar
detection all kinds of other things so
they get used for retrieval it hasn't
always been super useful for retrieval
we thought would be more useful for the
retrieval we're doing because again our
queries are longer than a normal I our
problem query and so much of what's
going on is about the syntax and the
sentence thus far well let's look at one
of the topics this is topic number six
from last year and it's about a female
gal with diabetes and doesn't you know
it was not compliant and she has a skin
lesion and she's tried bushings and
creams but it isn't working in his
nosing looking at the defensive parts of
the sentence you'll see first of all
that it isn't that the grammar week the
parser we used was trained on a grammar
that is not medical so it doesn't know
about hba1c and it also doesn't know
about mellitus and so it it's not a
perfect dependency parse but it still
does capture a lot of useful information
right we know the female has the
diagnosis I mean oh the diagnosis of
diabetes even though they're not
immediately prox proximal to one another
in the sentence likewise we can know
some long range diet daya dependencies
like female and the elevated other
sentences we can capture similar other
information and I'll have if anybody
really really wants to see the details I
can talk later just one thing is the
types of the dependencies are each
dependency parser is sort of
implementing a different linguistic
formal model and and this one and each
in each formal model will have different
types of dependencies and ours is the
Stanford model and it sort of just it's
got about 30 or 40 classes of dependency
in it and and they're all fairly
straightforward grammatical ones here's
a particular in particularly interesting
sentence it figures out that lesion and
leg are that the lesion is on the leg
even though its way the heck further
away in the sentence that comes in handy
later so our initial results results are
promising we have increased precision on
a number of the topics we're still not
getting amazing results were getting
much better results than ER than our
unigram baseline and what's really
probably what's really important to me
is that the results that were the
articles that were retrieve
that we weren't before are really tricky
ones that we probably would not have
been able to get without without using
the dependencies so for example on the
topic about the the diabetic woman with
the skin lesion one of the relevant
results that we had not retrieved with a
simpler model is this one here about a
metformin allergy and our unigram model
did retrieve it but it scored it very
very very badly and didn't didn't make
it into the threshold for for including
but because there's this noun now now
lesion skin relation in both the query
and the document it picked it up and you
know it basically is mean that the
grammatical unit of skin lesion has a
thing right that this is like an actual
unit as opposed to just two words is
it's being able to wait that more
heavily than just two words that it
appeared next to each other so I mean
yeah okay this example looks like just a
fancy way of getting we could index by
grams and get the same result for
different reasons but we'd get the same
result but here's another relevant
article for that query that we got back
this is about necrosis lipid the poi de
cod I begged diabetic I can't even
pronounce that I'm sorry that bad stuff
happening on your lipid Flippa tissue
because of diabetes I'm assuming and we
were able to retrieve it because both
the query and the document had a
preposition relation between lesion and
legs so we're like lesion on a leg even
though the sentences were completely
different so in ours right the lesion
the dependency comes from this place
here way far away and in the document it
was you know disseminated lesions on the
legs so even a more simplistic n-gram
based approach would never have picked
these up as being related to one another
the dependency model is capturing that
relationship so we think this is pretty
cool and promising and we'll be curious
to see where where it goes from there so
there's a bunch of things we still
haven't tried yet there's those 35
dependency types we've sort of
arbitrarily picked a subset of about 10
or 15 that seem to be most useful but
there's
a lot of hand waving their we'd like to
have better reasons for which ones we're
picking and be able to explain why we're
doing it I still think it's worthwhile
to integrate madam at maybe we maybe we
would only be up wait dependencies that
are that are involved in match concepts
or something like that because maybe
those are more important we haven't
taken sunana me into account at all here
but maybe we can try and do something
but you know maybe dependencies are more
similar to one another according to how
synonymous the words in them are perhaps
maybe extremity and leg would be a
little bit more closely related than you
know leg and desk and it might be able
to tell that the dependencies involving
extremities and legs are related somehow
that's all sort of future stuff and then
sort of to that and we're experimenting
with latent semantic analysis and so far
that hasn't done much for us yet but
it's it's it's early days with that so
stay tuned watch the skies there'll be
more coming from that hopefully in the
next few months and I would ordinarily
pause for any questions about that at
this point but I really want to get to
the next thing and I don't want to take
up everybody's like I want to go over
too much so if you let's hold questions
on the on the IR part to the end and
people can come talk to me after is that
okay great so shifting gears completely
another area that I'm working in and CSL
use on assistive technology this work is
with Melanie free token and her her team
in the Institute Institute on disability
and development and the idea here is
that there's a wide variety of
conditions that results in communication
issues right cerebral palsy people have
trouble communicating ALS or other kinds
of neurodegenerative diseases you can
get to a place where you can't you know
can't speak or can't use a computer so
there's a whole area of you know of
medicine really that's about you know
coming up with ultra alternative and
augmentative communication technologies
for people in these positions and that's
Melanie's group specialty so this
product is focusing on primary
progressive aphasia so aphasias are an
impairment of language affecting the
production or comprehension of speech
and the ability to read or write there's
a huge number of kinds of aphasias they
happen for all sorts of reasons the
particular kind that we are addressing
with the
project is primary progressive aphasia
which is also called frontotemporal
dementia and that is a nerd
neurodegenerative disease that targets
neurons that are involved in speech and
language and so people who have it have
extreme extreme difficulty with word
finding and that gets worse over time
and eventually other two other
neurocognitive cognitive effects kick in
and it's actually really tragic and
awful but what's interesting about it is
at epidemiology well it's an interesting
disease but also its epidemiology is
interesting so it's relatively rare
compared to like say Alzheimer's disease
but among early onset dementia is it's
actually over-represented so the average
age of onset I think I have down here is
about 60 which means that you have
people who are otherwise quite healthy
who suddenly are not able to produce
words and it gets worse over time so it
starts off with the I'm told it's very
much like the feeling of having that
word on the tip of your tongue except
it's like that all the time and so these
are people who are not you know elderly
and also sick for lots of other reasons
that are you know generally healthy and
now suddenly and are used to kind of
working and being out in the world
independent doing their thing and now
having a severe severe issue launch
expectancy post-diagnosis is about seven
to ten years and by the end the you know
the dementia does set in but there's a
number of years there where there you
know still quite functional except for
the whole language thing and obviously
the language thing has huge effects on
you know your ability to sort of get
through your life so standard treatments
include communication aids and
communication devices the sort of normal
one is as a picture board or a word
board where you've got this is a
screenshot of an of an app where each of
these is a word and you tap the word and
you can sort of a simple sentences or
there's also these sorts of displays
where it'll have lots of can phrases and
they can kind of point to the one that
they're trying to say or seeing it will
sort of jog there you know sort of jog
their word recall a little bit these
kinds of standard approaches have some
problems
they're often completely static in
nature meaning you get one and out of
the box it has what it has and that's it
or you configure it when you first get
it with your speech pathologist and they
work with you to figure out doing and
usually a spouse or some other you know
how number to figure out what words you
need to be able to say and they program
it in and that's what you have and if
you want to talk about something else
that day you're out of luck and also the
images so a lot of you have these image
images where you can put you know images
of your you know your spouse or your
child or you know the thing is the
subject you might want to talk about you
can preload in but they're pre loaded
and the way the interfaces with yourself
it's not a whole easy for the patient or
the user or their caregivers to do to do
any of the programming it generally has
to be done by the minute as a result any
patients basically don't use them no
more they under utilize them and that we
saw as a problem and so our solution is
just a time mixture board the idea is
the users can take their own darn
pictures because it's 2015 and we all
have phones in our pockets and iPads and
if we're talking about 60 year olds
they've all been carrying on smartphones
for the last five years at this point
and know perfectly well how to take a
picture even completely non tech
literate 60 year olds and 2015 like
that's okay but I'll just say like that
that is one of one of the things that
even people who don't know anything else
about their smartphone like many many
people who don't know any other
smartphone do know how to take a picture
and so that's so we see that like a
fairly achievable goal and and and so
anyway if you a picture of the problem
is this we can describe the pictures so
sort of having their clinician follow
them around and after they take the
picture type in the annotations you know
how you do it well we have found a way
for there to be real-time annotation and
the way we do it very right neat so our
model is that we have our user there's a
scene of interest going one to tell
somebody about later right so picture
imagine that you have PPA in your home
and your spouse is out shopping and the
fedex person comes and you of course
can't talk to the fedex person it tooks
you know to you know for what we you
can't talk the fedex person so you don't
as the door and they go and you want to
tell you
the FedEx person came and that they
should call fedex and schedule a
redelivery your your picture board does
not have fedex things programmed into it
so your scene of interest is the fedex
person at the door you know waving
frantically and your communication
partner is say your spouse when they
come back from the store he died in
another another group of participants to
this which is the friends and family of
the affected individuals we initially
also thought about maybe mechanical turk
that's later but for now we're talking
with friends and family and videos we'll
have them do the annotation so the user
takes the picture goes off into the
cloud are the other friends and family
annotated and gets them back to the
tablet and i'll talk more about the
details of how that happens in a bit i
just want to say the reason we're doing
friend of the family is he solves
obviously affecting the ability to speak
it had PPA has a huge impact on their
sort of social life so to speak right
it's very very common for people ph to
lose touch with friends because they
can't carry on a conversation you know
it's a it's really very isolating and
very challenging both for the affected
patient but also their family and their
caregiver and so by including the
friends and family that helps everybody
stay connected right people people who
you know know people whose friends get
PPA often report that they you know that
they would love to stay more in touch
with the friend but it's just hard
because they can't really talk we think
this might be a way to kind of help
bridge that gap by involving them in
their communication so the model works
like this we've got the user they have a
tablet computer they take a picture of
the scene of interest the photo in the
metadata get uploaded to our annotation
server where it gets sent their friends
and family we're thinking about things
like Facebook integration so the picture
shows up you know in their feed and they
can try to write a comment or maybe
there's a dedicated app and their phones
buzz and say hey you know Jane just took
a new picture can you write it write a
descriptive comment of it for her the
idea of course is we would sort of you
know the friends would sort of ahead of
time agreed to be doing this right you
you'd you know ask asks you know 10
friends if it'd be willing to help help
out with this and so that way the idea
it would be that people would be around
to do it the captions gets
oh the comments get sent back to the
annotation server where from there we
use natural language processing to
analyze the free text comments and come
up with a set of relevant relevant words
that describe what's going on in the
picture that we think the user might
want to you know use to describe what
they're seeing those get sent back to
the server which sends them back to the
tablet and then from there with their
with overs so it's not exactly real-time
but the idea is you know with you know
probably within an hour or two you could
get something back from from friends and
family and that would be you know wrap
it enough for for many use cases
obviously wouldn't solve everything but
it would be pretty darn useful we think
so this is actually a mock-up of the at
all be demoing the real thing here in a
minute hopefully but it is you see it
looks just much like any of the other
picture boards that I showed screenshots
of i like to think a little bit less a
little a little bit less ugly and the
ideas you have a picture and then
there's at words surrounding it there's
actually a lot of literature in the AC
world about how to organize these words
how many words there should be we're
exploring a number of different kind of
design options there so this is a
picture of a delicious bowl of pho and
so we have lots of you know file related
words here's a picture of the other
faculty member who was working on this
Whitney who is now google and he's out
in the park drinking tea and so we have
you know relevant words then so the
current status is we have that we have
an arch arch when we're in the middle of
the first year of an r21 from the nidcd
and we're building the NLP engine the
goal of which is to given those again
given those comments identify a set of
words that we would want to put around
it and we're also building the app in
the annotation system with help from oak
tree which is being very very useful and
the next step that is that is planned in
the grant is once we have the app built
we can be doing a small scale pilot
study using a single subject design
where the users are there sort of own
controls with about think we're shooting
for ten subjects the ideas will have
them attempt
you know we'll have them together with
an aria be out doing a thing we'll have
them take some pictures of whatever does
the task of they're doing and then come
back and try and tell their partner
about it using a wrap then have them do
kind of a similar activity without
without the support of the app and then
also a version just with the picture to
prompt them not without any of the words
or the other things so we're working on
the experimental design for that to
figure out how to how to make it how to
make it all work so for the pilot we're
not using friends and family for the
annotation that without thought that was
sort of unfeasible given the time and
budget constraints so we're just using
Ras as to sort of stand in for that the
outcomes are things like how many target
words are they producing so for each
interaction the RAS are coming up with
what kinds of words update to be sending
to describe what they were doing like
for example if it was the going out for
Vietnamese food we might expect to be
one of the words or soup or something
like that so of the target words how
many other producing honestly just how
many words are they producing there's a
sort of school of thought in PP a
treatment that is any words they say our
good words right just getting them
talking at all is apparently a pretty
big achievement and so we're we're
looking to just produce speech and
gentle so when like briefly about how
that NLP engine works so we have these
words and let's say that the comments on
that picture where things like like this
right so we know that some of these
words are quite relevant and we're
actually you know what let's say they'll
say that these were the words we picked
up not all the words might like to pick
have on the board though are in these
comments right we might we might say
that these are some of the more relevant
words but there's a bunch of stuff that
we might want that isn't isn't directly
in the comments so we have to have a way
to introduce new words to the equation
so for example no one said coffee
there's a cup of joe but they didn't say
coffee and probably somebody wanting to
tell it tell about the scene will
probably want to you know coffee ova
like a much more likely and much more
you know simple word so our idea is to
try to basically expand it work from the
work from the quark from the comments
and come up with a set of semantically
related words that has a couple
properties it needs to maximize
relevance so similarity between the
words that we suggest and the words in
the comment well the same time
minimizing redundancy because we don't
want to have ten synonyms for coffee
that won't help anybody so we need a
diverse set of words but they have to be
highly relevant so a a optimal solution
well just to highlight even more if a
maximally relevant solution will have
lots of words that are just like the the
comments but will be all redundant a
maximally diverse one will have a huge
variety of words that might might not be
very relevant but they'll be very
different for another so we want to try
to balance these two maximizing
relevance while minimizing redundancy so
more formally we we can look at it this
way we want to find the the maximize the
weighted difference right and the weight
is waiting parameter here is tunable so
if we we can kind of find the right
balance between relevance and redundancy
on a sort of / well on a per suggestion
basis you know that you can think of a
dozen different ways to try to cope with
that parameter and that's all future
future work the relevancy Rebellion's
and redundancy functions we're defining
using a fairly simple I are influenced
model so the relevance of a suggestion
to a query is just for each suggested
term how similar is that terms of the
query and then summed up the road on g
function is very similar except it's the
the sum of the terms all the other terms
for the redundancy we're using the word
tyvek semantic vector embedding model
that has been all the rage lately it
uses recurrent neural networks and
actually gets really interesting results
so the way they first evaluated it was
on a analogy solving task so the task is
you get athens is to Greece as oslo as
to what or you or you might have
actually just been you get appens as to
greece you need to find two words that
are that are that are you know in the
same relationship it actually worked you
know very very well i can if anyone's
interested i can go into more detail
about how that works later on but the
idea then is is we use that to compute
that the similarity function we just use
the word tyvek embedded model and say
for this word how similar these other
the problem with the sort of approach is
finding optimal solution is np-complete
it turns out which is sad because that
means that it's probably not tractable
to find an optimal approach right it's
it's analogous to a covering problem
right because there's a very large
number of possible words and
exhaustively exploring the space is
exponentially hard so we're all the good
news though is that there's a ton of
algorithms that try to you know come
without approximate solutions that which
is what we're right now we're using a
fairly simple greedy algorithm we're
exploring with a number of other ones
and actually we just found out that
there is a IBM has a linear linear
programming solver that claim is Google
to solve these kinds of things optimally
and in a few so we'll we'll see if that
works so right now we have a fairly
simple system working so from this
picture let's say we had these comments
this is actually real data this is from
our we had our our research team give us
a few pictures and then generate some
comments that we've used as a kind of
tweak our model so these implements and
our things just the following words so
that's pretty good right you know if you
had if you had this picture and I just
told you that these were the words I was
going to give you to pump to talk about
it those would all be fairly reasonable
right so what i thought i would do is
put on the safety goggles here and
attempts a live demo and before i hook
up the ipad people have laptops open
anybody wants to try to go to that
address and i probably should have
thought more about how to use that work
that still work still works good the
silver is still running excellent did
not did not crash during the course of
the talk ok so anybody who cares has has
seen that I should I leave it up for
another second ok
yeah port 3000 I I do apologize for not
having an easier to to deal with URL oh
geez I'm sorry that good my God thank
you mad well this is just running off my
laptop right now so yes thank you very
much so man who pointed that out is the
oak tree developer who has been helping
out amazingly with the website with the
website of things okay some of them are
rather large images yes or well earlier
earlier versions did not scale the image
is down and it turns out that um yes yes
you may allow an incoming connection am
I using up all my verizon data by
downloading this is if you're on the
Wi-Fi then are you able to access it
yeah so you have to be on me what is it
this is just running like I said on
Hawkeye on my laptop so ok anyway my
computer decided there didn't want to
show that slight anymore anyway so i
will just trust that a few of you have
it open and i'm going to hook up the
tablet and ok so it looks basically like
just in this current form like any photo
list right and now i'm going to take a
new photo now we observed that some of
our initial tests revealed that hitting
a small target initially had this be the
button to add a photo that is it
apparently well not apparently obviously
is way too small for somebody especially
if they have any kind of motor difficult
to get hit so now we've got a nice big
button and it also does not require you
to use apple's annoyingly it turns out
that this is a once you actually count
there's a lot of tapping involved in
taking it i know said oh super easy to
take a picture but it turns out there's
a lot of tapping involved so i'm going
to take a pic i'm going to take a
picture here i'm going to try taking a
minute here take one of Bill all right
there we go come on oh yes thank you all
right awesome okay so we've got a
picture of Bill a blurry picture of Bill
but we have to blur pictures of bill
okay I see people are reading comments
this is excellent so on the website now
hopefully that new picture appeared did
it anybody who's looking at it it
uploaded good so one of these I'm seeing
some people letting comments which is
good or loading it so if maybe maybe
maybe i'll switch back to the laptop so
we can all see so Oh hold that thought
about the interface look like as soon as
we took the picture it uploaded it to
the website and if I go to the website
now we have our picture of Bill the idea
here is that we could write comments you
know what a nice department oh I'm sorry
I'm not marrying all right what a nice
department this is a riveting talk and
nobody is asleep okay good so do 11 more
here the room is full good
and did it okay what's supposed to
happen and I have a Potemkin demo with
screenshots for it was working
immediately before the talk and now it
is not working and I don't know why is
this 93 this is 93 let's try one more
huh okay what normally happens and was
supposed to happen is the tablet is
supposed to be receiving the comments in
real time and it was happening right
before the talk go figure and oddly is
not now and then the idea is on the
tablet it might be I think maybe my
tablet Wi-Fi hiccup I don't know so from
here if if if it was doing what it's
supposed to do which of course it isn't
it gets sent back down and there's the
words appear you see the comments on the
side and then there's a synthesizer
built-in right which is much more
interesting when it's saying things like
soup but I have it I have a screenshot
of it doing that earlier today so let me
go back to keynote okay there we go so
this is what it looks like when it's
actually working and and its really need
you can as new comments coming you see
the words change in real time I have no
idea why it isn't working probably
because I knew I was demoing it but
always prepared how to screenshot right
and so the idea is the user will have
this and they'll be able to take it with
them and if they are prompt you know if
alone jogs the memory and that's what
they want to say they can say it or they
can just tap the button in the tab will
save for them we have all kinds of other
ideas for the interface that we want to
do the NLP engine the next step with it
is we realized that just adding new
words in the equation isn't sufficient
because often even though the words from
the comments don't always have
everything we want they often will still
have useful words and the system as it
is right now just
just new ones or rather yes if just
Jessica suggest new and so we're working
on identifying the most relevant words
from the comments we're also working on
recognizing noun phrases and proper
nouns so if they say I'm having coffee
with bill bill would be one of the
choices because it would know that bill
is a name and therefore you probably
want to talk about who's in the isn't
the picture Dave so I don't know this is
relevant to your particular problem but
it seems like and maybe I didn't
understand your how you unpack relevance
for this but you clearly like with
coffee or you're finding a synonym of a
word that was on the search on the query
but you're picking that synonym for some
reason I wonder one how you do that and
two is it if it's by frequency it seems
like that's a way to solve your
algorithmic issues for the time it takes
the NP completeness because you could
have it much smaller subsets of words
that are much more frequently used a
little bit adapted like you said for
their common friends and family or other
proper nouns rather than trying to solve
this whole entire you know lexical space
just by saying any word could show up
here so even for a fairly small number
of number of words it blows up
exponentially but that is a good idea
that is that is a very good idea and I
think there's some optimizations we
could do along those lines as to the
first part of your question about how we
decide kind of what's relevant that's
what we're still figuring out I think
what we'll end up doing in the end is
probably giving a lot more weight to
that words that are actually in the
comments that seem especially if it's a
word that multiple comments you know
include or a a set of very closely
related words that a lot of the comments
include we want to make sure to include
one of those you know there's a lot of
fine tuning about that part of what I
think is so interesting about this
project is unlike many other NLP things
there's kind of an obvious evaluation
story here right it's easy to have a
human look at it and ran rate whether
this set of words a better than a set of
words is it even have like a fully
extrinsic pipeline planned out where we
have you know users and we have
for a number of fairly good objective
measures for you know measuring how you
know how well they're doing using the
system and that that's that so you know
in principle if we had two different
algorithms that we wanted to try for
pick'em of these words we could
experimentally you know investigate that
in a way that is fairly uncommon in a
lot of NLP tasks so anyway that's a I'm
sorry the demo didn't work there I swear
it really was working five minutes
before they like I tried it right before
the talk on anyway that's um that's what
I wanted to cover I'm just over time it
looks like so I'll take questions but
first I want to thank the people have
been working with so obviously for the
IR piece we have bill and Aaron and
Tracy edinger and Kate photos for the
trek stuff and then Joel Adams and go on
our sheykh job and Joseph Hamilton or
CSL you students have work with me on on
this or other I our projects in the in
the past and then on the AC stuff we
have melon her whole team Amy and glory
and bets and Kyle and also the oak tree
folks who've been really amazing and
really done a lot of good work on the
web side so oh and of course the funders
who are paying for which is really kind
of awesome so anyway that's what i had
for today and i'll be more than happy to
take any questions that people haven't
already asked okay is you said that one
of the problems or things that would
benefit you and doing this is having
more text so I wonder how if you could
reference like Google Images has a lot
of people going in and texting the
writing text for those images if you
could use that as a source to pull like
send it your most common or most
interesting words see what other
relevant words you get relative to other
people matching with those images and
therefore get a better list of like
secondary words that you can so you let
me rephrase if I understand quite right
you're saying we should take the picture
run through google images see what other
related images are and use words from
that or the words that your algorithm
picks
there's more relevant in your comments
and try to get more words from LIC doing
it do a Google Images search with those
words as the query and then take yeah
that's definitely something those kinds
of ideas are things we're thinking about
we're also looking into there's been a
lot of progress and last two years on
automatic image captioning it's still
much better at like describing the
objects in an image than what they're
doing with each other right it'll say
many people will lined up in a line and
that'll be factually correct but it'll
be missing the point that they're all
waiting in line to get into a movie
theater or something like that but we're
thinking about trying to integrate those
kinds of automated solutions as well so
yeah that's that's definitely a good a
good idea yes yeah that's on the plan is
some kind of relevance feedback from
users saying nope you no swiping what
are housing to some app now that people
use for dating where you like swipe left
or yeah we're so something like that for
the words where to i'm i'm apparently
old and don't know about these things
and so with that is that they did you
know swipe one way on the words to make
them go away and then get a new set of
suggestions up something like that we're
also thinking about having some kind of
more organization for it so you know
maybe it shows the 10 but then there'll
be you know sections at the bottom like
verbs or you know more names or you know
think things alone along those lines
that's all stuff that were sort of we
have a bucket of ideas we're calling I
you know this is the RO one bucket so
all stuff they were going to put in we
when we when we apply for an ro1 to
continue the work it's actually been
very educational for me to see how much
you have to constrain to fit into an
hour 21 we had we had many grandiose
visions that we've sort of chopped off
to fit in the timeline yeah have you
ever considered the possibility of some
sort of crowdsourcing way of generating
our first thought initially was
mechanical turk actually for that was
our very first thought and then the the
clinicians thought that the problem
Mechanical Turk would be that the
Turkish I guess they were there that
their intuition was a lot of the
pictures people are going to want to
take will be of like
friends or family or stuff the turquoise
won't have enough context to interpret
that doesn't mean we shouldn't use them
though IIIi think there's definitely a
role for crowdsourcing to play I mean
the more comments the better right and
then we can talk about well do we wait
ones from friends and family more
heavily than ones for Mechanical Turk or
you know things along those lines that's
definitely something we want to
experiment with yeah yeah oh right I
made this so this disease is progressive
which means at some point they're
probably these patients have some access
to words is there a thought I mean I
warned the feature of sort of recording
the words they typically use and having
working from a more reduc reduced
dictionary that's an idea that they
certainly do things like voice banking
for other degenerative diseases I don't
know that anyone's tried that with PPA
this would be a really good way to
elicit that though you know part of what
we want to do with this is a user uses
it over time they'll be building up a
personalized library of scenes and words
that they that they can refer back to
and certainly somebody in the earlier
stages we could be saving that and and
and using using those for sure you know
we also have ideas about maybe looking
at their you know getting writing
samples or looking at their contact on
their other device and and seeing you
know what what name should we be looking
out for specifically or email
correspondence any of that kind of stuff
yeah for sure good idea oh okay i
actually had sort of three
recommendations or things you might put
in that bucket one is it might be
interesting to cluster similar words so
then thinkin you know drill down another
interesting idea is allowing the user to
annotate the image so they can you know
circle what they've got says on yes and
another idea might be allowing sort of
crowdsourcing within the group of people
who have an aphasia maybe not so much
offering up words but having a word
sharing program so if someone sees an
image they go I think this bucket of
words applies oh that's that's a really
idea yeah so the the first two are
definitely one to want to do especially
the one about letting the user indicate
when they take the picture ok now I
really want you know the the computer is
what I'm trying to talk about not other
people in the background you know give
it being all to communicate that to
their annotators is definitely something
we want to do the for sure the last one
though about having some kind of like
shared library of photos among all the
users of the app or something that's a
really neat idea we hadn't I hadn't
thought of that one that's very cool
yeah yes i can certainly stick around so
thank you everyone for your attention